political polarization in America is an
increasing problem as the years go by my
questions kind of tie into each other
the first one is what do you believe is
the root cause of this problem and the
second is how would you go about fixing
that ah great question so I'm excited
about this because I'm writing an entire
book on it right now so I think that the
root cause of the political divisions in
Americans site in Western civilization
more broadly is that there is a Tilos
shaped hole in our heart that is now
being filled with tribalism so that's a
very complicated way of saying that the
Telos means purpose for those who are
not philosophy students in the
Aristotelian and Platonic view the way
that you derive your value as a human
being is by acting in accordance with
with net and nature's law essentially
that if you look at the universe what
you see is that man is a creature of
reason if you act in accordance with
that reason then you are acting in
accordance with your purpose and there's
a whole set of virtues that you have to
cultivate in order to act best in
accordance with your identity as a
reason to person and Aristotle
recommends these judeo-christian values
seem to mirror these pretty strongly
which is why for for basically the
entire medieval scholastic period there
was a great identity between a wrist is
healing and thought and judeo-christian
values and that carried forward all the
way through most of the Enlightenment
actually despite some pushback to the
contrary the American Founding was based
on this this essential idea that every
right has a corresponding duty that you
are that you have a purpose in the
universe that is laid forth in a
religious level by your religious
community by the Bible and on a on a
reasonable level by a universe that
requires certain things if you under
natural law right this is what the
founders talks about when they talk
about natural law I think all of that's
been lost I think it's been
systematically undermined by 200 years
of philosophy that says that God does
not exist the Bible is a fraud
that you cannot get to aught from is
right to the David Hume distinction that
just because the universe is a certain
way doesn't mean that's how you you
ought to be and once you do that and you
say that everybody make your own purpose
it turns out people are not good at
making their own purpose when people try
to make their own purpose they end up
usually at hedonism or at self-interest
or at the triumph of the will or at the
idea that if we shaped together as a
community then we can create utopia
together and you've seen all of those
things happen in the 20th century I
think now the most common may the most
common area in which people are finding
fulfillment is tribalism because our
sense of community has broken down
much because religious communities have
declined people don't see each other as
neighbors or friends anymore we look at
the United States and we don't see a set
of common principles that we all hold to
I mean there's a perfect example tonight
we need probably dozens of security
members just me to talk we don't have
the same set of values anymore because
of that people are filling that hole
with tribalism they're filling that hole
with okay there's a bunch of people who
look like me and therefore those are my
people and I'll stand up for their
interests and you see this I think to a
certain extent the black lives matter
movement I think you certainly see in
the alright movement and all of these
tribal movements are deeply disturbing
and and cut against the grain of Western
thought which has been moving toward
individuality and universalism
simultaneously for the past several
thousand years and is now moving I think
in a completely sideways direction
thanks to the undermining of these key
concepts purpose an individual purpose
the capacity of individuals to take
control their lives
communal purpose and the capacity of a
community to to set boundaries around
individual behavior so far it doesn't
hurt other people and also the seeds to
ensure people's freedom